Marjorie Taylor green
has a boyfriend he's the guy from right
side broadcasting network I know and uh
it turns out he is dressed in Drag
and of course she's defending him I'm
kicking these shoes off but I may keep
the pantyhose on it does feel kind of
good actually I'm not gonna pee in him I
promise so of course Marjorie Taylor
green would denounce this right because
she's against this she says this is
grooming and this is dangerous and it's
obscene and no she defends it Marjorie
Taylor green taking to Tweeter where she
posted quote I'm literally loling Brian
Glenn dressed in drag for Morning News
in Dallas years ago reporting on an
upcoming local theater production and
the morons over at Patriot takes think
this is an attack these people are
completely and totally vapid there is
nothing there